so let's start if we could on what I
might call the macro crisis an Anatole I
wonder if you can just start us off how
do we not solve the problem of
depressions are we not now living in
something that feels a bit like a
depression it's certainly comparable to
the 30s and what went wrong there well I
think the short answer is yes we did
solve it I think in your introduction
you said canes and his followers
believed that the problem had been
solved and I think they're right the
problem the trouble is that of course
the solutions have not been implemented
Cain said actually at the time of the
Second World War he was very
disillusioned man because actually the
only country that implemented his ideas
and fall in the 1930s in Europe was Nazi
Germany and he actually said I now
realize that although my analysis is
correct this is broadly what he said our
democratic governments will never have
the decisiveness to implement my
recommendations except in times of
warfare which is exactly what happened
the second world war broke our
government started spending as if
literally there was no tomorrow they
started printing money and lo and behold
full employment was returned so I think
in that sense it's a fairly simple
answer and the only thing I'd add is
that right now there is a very
interesting controlled experiment going
on in the world between this country and
the united states and basically the
united states rather feebly is
implementing a Keynesian policy and has
been for the last three years Britain
was for a couple of years after the
crisis but then abruptly changed in
early 2010 for reasons we all know
political reasons we all know so for the
last year and a half Britain America
have been trying opposite policy
prescriptions for the same crisis and I
think over the next year we're going to
find out which is right the indication
so far
is that the American economy now is
recovering and personally I think we'll
be in an all-out boom by the end of this
year and we're not so I think in a
year's time come back and I think we'll
know the Omega ring success by the first
year effect of the stimulus policy as
opposed to the 10-year effect when
they're paying back or whatever the
extranet Steve yes I I wanted to kick
off with just an observation about this
comparison with the depression the
depression was far worse than anything
we've so far been through and I say so
far because things might get far worse
but US national income fell by thirty
percent from peter trough a total utter
collapse the come you haven't seen his
time around US mail unemployment rose at
about twenty five percent of the
workforce in nineteen thirties again we
haven't seen anything quite like that
and i think policies have worked
extremely well to prevent that from
happening there was massive stimulus
both in terms of monetary and fiscal
policy the problem has been that we've
avoided something we thought we were
never going to be suffering from and we
haven't avoided something we thought we
could avoid and the thing that people
thought we could avoid was a japan-style
stagnation japan the stagnation over the
last twenty years most Western policy
makers thought they knew why Japan has
stagnated to failure to lose macro
policy sufficiently well and the
consequence was that we thought we could
prevent a Japan type situation we've
actually done is prevented a depression
but we seem to have ended up with
something which looks uncannily like
Japan stagnation lack of growth very
high levels of debt deleveraging
continue to take place over time and we
got to the point now where interest
rates credibly low fiscal policy not
really offering much in the way of
staying with us and maybe we just got to
the point where the ammunition
eventually has run out so we've done
something good but it hasn't been good
enough to return to us to conditions as
were the case prior to the crisis just
clarify where you are on austerity I
mean so essentially Anatole says we know
the solution we just aren't doing it is
that your view well I think the US is
lucky the u.s. is lucky because it has
the world's reserve currency it's very
easy for us to borrow from the
to the world very easily in the way that
it's very difficult for say Greece or
Spain or Portugal did Barbara for the
rest of the world's there's a big
difference it turns a view the US credit
or debtor position and so for that point
of view and I think that the u.s. can
get away with things that others can't
get away with but at the same time if
you look at the levels of government
debt as a share of national income both
in the States and across Europe that you
find there's been only three occasions
previously over the last 100 years where
government debt has been this high
immediately after the First World War
where some countries dealt with that
through hyperinflation which is a pretty
nasty experience in the middle of the
Depression in the 1930s where you had a
situation where income basically
collapsed and governments defaulted and
immediately after the Second World War
were actually things worked out pretty
well but that's because we found the
source of growth growth didn't come from
fiscal stimulus at Manchester murs it
came from the opening up of trade
opportunities the removal of Allah
protectionism that was in place in the
first half of the 20th century and the
problem is we have exploited as
opportunities now and we're now left for
something much more difficult it is
basically stagnation Linda you're a
notable macro you were you wrote the
textbook macroeconomic ago wrote the
textbook where do you stand on the the
macroeconomic pickle we're in and I
agree with what he said so far in that
and I think the difficulty for the
British economy and for quite a lot of
governments which don't issue the
world's reserve currency is that the
only way to get your debt to a
sustainable level is somehow your
economy is growing faster than the rate
of growth of your dad and how fast your
debt grows depends on the borrowing
costs the interest rate that you pay on
that debt so if you issue the world's
reserve currency then you benefit from
having wealth low boring cause as the
United States does but for other
countries there's always a danger that
boring costs could shoot off because the
country could be viewed as not being
credible and bringing down their debt
over time and given the slow rate of
growth in Britain which is very common
after a financial
Isis then the worry is that our economy
is extremely slowly growing and should
bar in cost you top it could make it
quite untenable and I think that's where
the reality of markets plays into the
theory of austerity and debt
sustainability and let me just make a
caveat my textbook maybe the recommended
text for the government economic service
but I cannot vouch that anybody has
actually read it in the service give you
yeah i mean i think that the debate so
far has posed the question quite nicely
are we more like the u.s. in which case
we've got all this latitude that Anatole
thinks were not exploiting or should we
be really worrying about being more like
Greece and Spain and Italy in which case
Osborne's absolutely right and we've
really got to get control of the dead
otherwise we're going to be caught in
the kind of nightmarish situation where
we can't service our debt and we have to
cut in the very very uncontrolled way
that they're doing and get into this
downward spiral my suspicion is that
we're you know we're probably halfway in
between which is why it's a it's a
difficult dilemma we've got some of the
historic credibility that the US has we
know we haven't default on our debt for
many many years so there may be some
sort of latitude there on the other and
we don't issue the world's reserve
currency and I do think there's a danger
there's a bit of crowing in Britain when
France lost its triple-a status I think
that could happen to Britain in within
within the next year or so and just a
final thought on the u.s. I mean it is
true that they have this great advantage
of having the world's reserve currency
which does give them more latitude but I
wonder whether in the end it actually
could be a source of damage to them
because it allows them to continue with
potentially unsustainable policies for
it for even longer it's a bit like an
athlete who gets a pain killing
injection so it allows them to play on
the field for a long long but actually
damage of themselves as they do it and I
think that there may be an element of
that with the United States and that's
all I wanted to just push you a bit
because actually the really interesting
difference between the u.s. and the UK
is not just that they have a reserve
currency so they can rely on the markets
more than us it's that they have a
closed economy and virtually all the
economic models out there will tell you
that an extra 10 billion dollars of
pounds of borrowing in the US
generates about 12 billion 15 billion of
extra national income all those models
tell you in the UK if we spent borrowed
10 billion more we'd get three to five
billion pounds of extra national income
now that's not a lot really is it you're
stacking up a lot of debt for a tiny bit
of extra income uh yeah I think you've
cornered me I think that I think that's
the right question i think the reserve
currency issue is complete red herrings
complicit of you to get back onto my
territory it's a completely irrelevant
in the sense that you know this idea
that America has some big advantage
because the dollar is just doesn't hold
true look around the world Japan hasn't
got a reserve currency Australia hasn't
got a reserve currency Canada Sweden
Switzerland they all have no problem
borrowing at all the point is that the
key difference between Greece and and
all these is that they have a control
over their own currency they have their
own central bank we have the Bank of
England if the government can't borrow
from the markets it just turns the bank
of england and the bank of england
prints the money so the only thing that
restrains government borrowing is not
the reserve currency it's the fear of
inflation right so that so that that so
i think the reserve currency argument is
not valid I think Evans argument about
we are more dependent on trade clearly
as it is valid but trade is thirty
percent at most of the British economy
it's true it's only about twelve percent
of the u.s. so so we don't have we only
have half their freedom of maneuver no
it would a reason only work as well yet
to explain to the audience that means
that every pound we reject half of it
just drifts overseas well more like that
I would said but the multipliers are
very very single yeah and it does depend
a lot on how you spend the money so I
think arguably the best way to spend the
money if you want to stimulate the
economy is actually for the government
to spend it on domestic activities
you're a building roads digging roads
something something that employs British
workers directly the counter argument
which I must say I'm quite sympathetic
to is that although it's true that that
stimulates the economy more directly
it's
also tends to be a most wasteful kind of
spending and a form of spending that
can't be turned off well once the
economy revives so the opposite point of
view is don't spend money don't spend
extra money through the government cut
taxes give people more spending power
but that is subject to Evans objection
that if I give you each a hundred pounds
of spending power you would probably
spend at least 30 pounds of it on
foreign goods right anyone else on the
panel want to come in on this I mean
it's a very I think we've got some I
think there's a fundamental question
which people was to argue it auto answer
which is how we got into this mess and
unfortunately the reason in my opinion
I'm not an economist so the room is
certainly all these clever people will
disagree with me is that the democratic
societies in Europe and the United
States and elsewhere as well to some
extent promised people far more than
they were producing and hence colossal
trade imbalances occurred that didn't
apply in China where they don't bother
about public opinion so much and there
was a reciprocal of those imbalances and
whenever you see this is going to be
contradicted by all these economists
whenever you see trade imbalances
persisting on an absolutely enormous
scale you know perfectly well that the
debtor the deficit countries are
overspending and that's where the
trouble comes from and we've got to
correct it and we've got to correct it
particularly in the UK where we have
this ghostly debt overhang by a
government last government Prime
Minister enriched himself but
impoverished the rest of us right but
take John and then Thomas thank you so
much
I think there's a significant element of
truth in what Martin has just said and
in fact I think if we go over the
various contributions we've heard and
pick elements out of it we can come up
with an eclectic story that defines the
predicament were now in I think Anatole
is right we know how to fix these
problems in the sense that if we had
gone into the present crisis with
well-managed domestic finances and an
under control banking system we could
have responded with Keynesian remedies
and we would have had emerged from it
relatively well and Anatole has
described correctly the sort of thing we
ought to be doing its construction which
is most hit in almost any downturn and
its construction which is the mechanism
for getting you out of it we ought to be
building more houses not less we haven't
build enough houses for a long time and
we ought to be doing small-scale
projects that have been neglected for
two decade through three decades in fact
it's the one mile of extra dueling on
the a21 which has not been done for 20
years it's a whole series of small scale
projects like that that's where our
public expenditure ought to be directed
we have some scope to do that but not
very much and the reason we don't have
scoped to do that is firstly that we
went into this recession with public
finances that had been wildly
imprudently managed for six or seven
years whatever reputation mr. Brown
managed to retain from his early years
as he became more and more responsible
in his later years and we had a banking
system which imploded more than the
banking system of any other major
country at the time and that's why it's
very difficult for us to manage the
financial consequences as steven has
been saying of the of the kind of
Keynesian paulo
which Anatole has correctly said unknown
to be the right ways of dealing with
this kind of situation was a very good
synthesis another than a very agreeable
consensus building and taught it Thomas
I'd like to get the history the pissed
or inspected it's not the historians
perspective it's like that you know the
troublemakers perspective and by the way
thank thanks for inviting here it's a
great honor and what I write about is
the American right the political right
in America and when I hear your
description of you know Britain choosing
one path in America choosing the other
I'm like what I don't know what America
you're talking about i mean i know i'm
sorry i'm giving you a hard time and I
don't mean to because I know you know
President Obama got this enormous
stimulus package passed when he was
first first elected and that was really
wonderful and you know in the economy in
america in the united states might well
turn around but when we talk about you
know why depressions are awful and why
we should dread you know deep recessions
there's there's two different schools of
thought one is you know people who don't
like the idea of bread lines okay and
who don't want to be poor and the other
is people who don't want to be regulated
ok this is there's there's a lot of
people in America who look back to the
1930s and the disaster that they
remember from the last go-around is that
that's when they got things like
organized labor that's when they got
things like the Securities and Exchange
Commission you know that's when they got
the Roosevelt administration and that's
what they dread and here's the really um
here's the really creepy thing that I'm
here to report on to tell you about is
that the the sort of populist language
that you would associate with you know
someone like Franklin Roosevelt or
something like the 1930s is almost
entirely nowadays on the other side in
America is demanding austerity you know
demanding that we follow something like
what you guys have been doing over here
and is even you'll remember Herbert
Hoover's term for Andrew Mellon you know
Andrew Mellon was he was the secretary
of the Treasury in the United States in
the in the during the Great Depression
started and
his genius solution for everything was
to let everyone fail you know liquidate
What did he say the famous passage
liquidate the bankers liquidate the
liquidate labor liquidate the farmer
basically let everybody go down let them
all go to hell right and hurt he was
Herbert Hoover's Treasury secretary and
Hoover was Hoover was was not a great
present but he was smart smart enough to
know not to do that well get this this
is the funny thing today's sort of the
the big you know the movement out in the
streets in America today is demanding
that we do what melon wanted you know
let everyone go down watch the watch the
Republican presidential debates that are
going on right now you'll see this this
character Ron Paul he loves that term
liquidate you have to let it liquidate
you know if you if you if you look at
the famous of rant the CNBC ramp that
launched the Tea Party movement i know
i'm talking about something that you
aren't familiar with here but basically
what started this populist movement in
america was a demand that we that that
people need to fail losers need to lose
okay it's a moral argument winners need
to win losers need to lose losers need
to be punished and we know who they are
right and they need to go down we need
to let the the economy take its moral
course which is smiting these people
okay that's that's what's and and yes I
know President Obama hasn't done any
that and he's the president he's
ultimately who calls the shots but these
are the people who who had this who
brought about this disastrous showdown
in America over the the debt ceiling a
few months ago and managed to wreck our
credit rating thank you very much topics
that was very
karim see I'm going to ask I've no lies
down one question which is we've sort of
heard how the technology that we have at
our disposal has got us into Japan we've
turned into Japan stagnation I just want
to ask then before I throw for a few
questions is that really such a crisis
Japan's not that bad does anybody really
think that's kind of a crisis quick
reflection down and then we'll open to
the floor it's been very interesting
listening to these and comments there's
an old joke there are three kinds of
economists those who can open those who
can't actually there are there are two
kinds of economist so as a macro
economists and the micro economists and
I do the micro kind which is all about
how businesses take decisions to invest
and produce new technologies and how
consumers make that make their choices
and I actually think that if you look at
the record of macro economist before
2008 it's a little bit unseemly of them
to claim to know what's going on now and
the intellectual failure of
macroeconomics beforehand should make us
a bit more modest about about the claims
we make to understand what's going on
now but the lesson from Japan I thing
and actually from history as well as a
terrific book by carmen reinhart and Ken
Rogoff about the history of debt crises
and I think it shows very clearly that
even if you have a structural budget
deficit and you've got to address that
because the government can't forever
carry on spending more than it takes in
revenues the way you get out of debt
crises is either you have an inflation
which is socially disruptive and unfair
to little people whose earnings don't
keep up and only have a little bit
savings or you or you grow out of it and
and the growth bit is the important bit
and that's all about the microeconomics
and is their competition actually
confirms that aren't doing very well
fail and go out of business so that new
ones can come in and do new inventions
get and get made and so Japan is a very
very prosperous society to get back to
your question but they're not doing any
growing and inventing anymore and
they've got an aging population and
they've not got any way to get out of
what they're in right so in that regard
it's not going well what I just want to
do is have a quick show of hands quick
show of hands how many of you would say
you by and large agree with the
proposition that an atoll started with
that essentially we could make this much
better if we abandoned or loosened the
plan area which the Chancellor's
following how many of you would say you
agree effectively with the sort of an
atoll we should spend and borrow more as
government should spend and borrow more
how many of you would say you'd be kind
of behind George Osborne plan a and
austerity as it is currently practiced
in the UK ok so i'd say probably
two-thirds one-third of those right
let's take a few questions we've got
some mics roving around there's
gentlemen there let's take just a couple
of points I want to move on very quickly
to the next week yes the judgment there
hi um actually I just look the question
is Dallas was conflicted with the point
you made earlier router open and close
economies and surely the problem we have
in Europe is that for any individual
government because you're faced with
local economy cutting spending is the
rational thing to do because I mean yet
if everybody does it simultaneously
which is what's happening in Europe now
you have this sort of grand crash across
it throughout the problem is that
coordination between governments it's a
collective action problems that actually
makes sense of all governments to spend
because they're now imports would help
other countries and then the I think
that's a very good point i'm not even
going to put into the panel it's so good
we don't need to get them to corrected
yes up at the top we've got somebody yes
have we yes sir just a question about
the the solution for debt problem is the
idea of the year of Jubilee where debt
is cancelled now that this was tried out
in in Nazi Germany in in the 30s what
when there was a when there was a
depression and it worked well what what
do the panel think of that that's a very
interesting wonder you know the Jubilee
concept every few years you you quickly
you've just cancel some debt I'm does
someone want to answer what the what the
downside of that is I can do it in about
a sentence but I don't know if any you
to do it John tell us what the downside
is the downside is what you're canceling
is basically people's pensions and not
only is that bad news well I hope for
everyone in this room actually because I
hope they will all live long enough to
be potentially able to receive their
pensions and it's pretty bad news for
the future as well because nobody is
going to have much enthusiasm for saving
in future either could I go ahead of
pensions it's your bank account it's the
man you've got no no but this is very
important what what the government
bailed out when it bailed out the banks
was not the bank has margin about it
basically bailed out your your your
ability to take a hundred pounds out
when you'd put a hundred pounds in the
bank rather than take 50 pounds out
though that's what it's all about that
is it for every loan there's someone
who's actually lent the money so let's
take the one over here I'm rushing
through it because I want to sir mr.
Franks I think I'm fairly character
caricatured the u.s. right there's a
perfectly respectable school of Austrian
economics said in actual fact the
Austrian economist with the only people
to consistently predict the financial
crisis and you're welcome to consult
Clips like Peter Schiff words right
where you can see continuous interviews
explaining why the easy credit was
leading to a financial crisis
commentators like a data like let's
carpal croup one of the beauties of
their columns is that there is a weekly
record of what they said and their views
on everything and if you look back to
2005 2006 you do not see any full
telling of the coming crisis yet the
Austrians aren't being consulted I don't
think there's an Austrian economist on
this paddle despite the fact that they
predicted the crisis ooh why should we
listen to the same people that said
everything was wonderful to guide us out
of our current predicament it's crazy
a round of applause for the gold
standard that's right folks so look the
reason the Austrians got it right is
because they're they're constantly
saying we're heading for disaster they
say all the time you know and you know
what they've been saying for the last
three years we're heading for
hyperinflation in America it hasn't
happened folks you know they've been
saying these are the people that are
that are I mean this is what the Tea
Party movement is all about let me just
um what what else was I going to say
about these people I don't know I look I
know it's the friends of mine who were
Jamie Galbraith was talking about the
disaster that was coming he's not an
Austrian Dean Baker famous not he's not
a famous economist he's but he was
talking about what was coming these
these were these are you know but I will
say the Freeman had lots of reservations
about that's right these these people
were that look there is something about
times of economic distress where
orthodoxy gets smashed and orthodoxy
deserves to be smashed and I say that as
a graduate of the University of Chicago
and they at least people these people
they deserve what's you know discredit
the the sort of mainstream economic
orthodoxy just as they did in the 1930s
what's very curious to me is that what's
happening what you see now in America is
rather than people turning to sort of
the Galbraith Ian tradition or their you
know the sort of traditional economics
of the left in America they're turning
to the sort of ron paul you know gold
standard kind of thing and that's it's
it's it's fascinating to me well anyhow
we can talk about that so we can we can
talk about a lot i'm going to close down
the discussion of the macro the
macroeconomics at that point